awful procession of her devoted husband
it is not possible for us to guess what
her majesty the queen
will be thinking
[Music]
[Applause]
but she once gave the phrase
to a great disaster in the world that
grief
is the price we pay for love
the armed forces will now carry the lord
high abnormal
to his funeral
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
her majesty the queen goes into the
galilee porch led by
dean of windsor and will be taken to her
seat
in the choir meanwhile
the armed forces continue to take
the duke to his point where at the
bottom of the steps
the final salute will be given
[Music]
foreign
the bearer party will now turn to square
up
their approach to the chapel
blue
as the duke of edinburgh is conveyed to
the second landing members of the royal
family will line up
at the bottom of the steps ready for the
one minute silence
we now prepare for the one minutes
silence
to mark the life of his royal highness
the duke of edibre
knight companion of the most noble order
of the garter
the royal marine bearer party now convey
his royal highness
the duke of edinburgh into his funeral
service
a lifetime of service done to his queen
his wife his family his nation
lord high admiral who sets down his
tasks
and comes into the great pantheon of
kings and princes who are buried here
into the company of edward iv henry vi
henry viii charles the first edward the
eighth
george v george vi
the home of the knights of the garter
knights that go back through history to
the time of cressy
in 1384.
passing through this chapel where his
banner as a knight of the garter hanged
for so many years
followed by his family we will shortly
hear the sentences
which will be sung by the choir of four
and then into a service which will
follow the music and wishes
of his royal highness the duke of edibre
[Music]
one
[Music]
the prince for whom faith meant so much
and
to this place he brought so much of his
investigation of
faith by setting up saint george's house
to
pursue that struggle between a pursuit
of god
and an understanding of the technology
and science of our world
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
foreign
shall never die
shall never
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we are here today in saint george's
chapel
to commit into the hands of god the soul
of his servant prince philip duke of
edinburgh
with grateful hearts we remember the
many ways in which his long life
has been a blessing to us
we have been inspired by his unwavering
loyalty
to our queen by his service
to the nation and the commonwealth
by his courage fortitude and faith
our lives have been enriched through the
challenges that he has set us the
encouragement that he has given us
his kindness humor
and humanity
we therefore pray that god will give
us grace to follow his example
and that with our brother philip at the
last
we shall know the joys of life
eternal
[Music]
it's
[Music]
on the sea
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
it
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
from
[Music]
a reading from the book ecclesiasticus
look at the rainbow and praise its maker
it shines with a supreme beauty
rounding the sky with its gleaming ark
a bow bent by the hands of the most
high
his command speeds the snowstorm
and sends the swift lightning
to execute his sentence
to that end the storehouses are opened
and the clouds fly out like birds
by his mighty power the clouds are piled
up
and the hailstones broken small
the crash of his thunder makes the earth
writhe
and when he appears an earthquake
shakes the hills
at his will the south wind blows
the squall from the north and the
hurricane
he scatters the snowflakes like
birds are lighting they settle
like a swarm of locusts
the eye is dazzled by their beautiful
whiteness
and as they fall the mind is entranced
he spreads frost on the earth like salt
and icicles form like pointed stakes
a cold blast from the north
and ice grows hard on the water
settling on every pool as though the
water
we're putting on a breastplate
he consumes the hills scorches the
wilderness
and withers the grass like fire
cloudy weather quickly puts all to
rights
and dew brings welcome relief
after heat
by the power of his thought
he tamed the deep and planted it with
islands
those who sail the sea tell stories of
its dangers
which astonish all who hear them
in it are strange and wonderful
creatures
all kinds of living things and huge
sea monsters
by his own action he achieves his end
and by his word all things
are held together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
for thy lord
[Music]
his mercy is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
as is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
me
[Music]
us
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
us
[Music]
oh
[Music]
with thy servant o lord
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
and let's fight
[Music]
in
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh merciful god the father of our
lord jesus christ who is the
resurrection and the life
in whom whosoever believeth shall live
though he die and whosoever liveth and
believeth in him
shall not die eternally
who also hath taught us by his holy
apostle saint paul
not to be sorry as men without hope for
them that sleep in him
we meetly beseech the o father
that when we shall depart this life
we may rest in him as our hope is this
our
brother doth and that
at the general resurrection in the last
day
we may be found acceptable in thy sight
and receive that blessing which thy
well-beloved son
shall then pronounce to all that love
and fear thee
saying come
ye blessed children of my father
receive the kingdom prepared for you
from the beginning of the world
grant this we beseech thee o merciful
father
through jesus christ our mediator
and redeemer amen
oh eternal god before whose face
the generations rise and pass away
thyself unchanged abiding
we bless thy holy name for all who have
completed their earthly course in thy
faith and following and are now at rest
we remember before thee this day philip
duke of edinburgh
rendering thanks unto thee for his
resolute faith and loyalty
for his high sense of duty and integrity
for his life of service to the nation
and commonwealth
and for the courage and inspiration of
his leadership
to him with all the faithful departed
grant thy peace let
light perpetual shine upon them and in
thy loving wisdom
and almighty power work in them
the good purpose of thy perfect will
through jesus christ our lord
amen
o lord who did give to thy servant saint
george
grace to lay aside the fear of man
and to be faithful even unto death
grant that we unmindful
of worldly honor may fight the wrong
uphold thy rule and serve thee to our
lives end
through jesus christ our lord
our men god save our gracious sovereign
and all the companions living and
departed
of the most honorable and noble order of
the garter
amen o god of the spirits of all flesh
we praise thy holy name
for thy servant philip duke of edinburgh
who has left us a fair passion of
valiant and true knighthood
grant unto him the assurance
of thine ancient promise that thou wilt
ever be with those
who go down to the sea in ships and
occupy their business in great waters
and we beseech thee that following his
good example and strengthened by his
fellowship
we may at the last together with him
be partakers of thy heavenly kingdom
through jesus christ our lord
amen
o lord god when thou give us
to thy servants to endeavor any great
matter
grant us also to know that it is not the
beginning
but the continuing of the same unto the
end
until it be thoroughly finished which
yieldeth the true glory
through him who for the finishing of thy
work
laid down his life our redeemer
jesus christ amen
almighty god father of all mercies
and giver of all comfort
deal graciously we pray thee with those
who mourn
that casting every care on thee
they may know the consolation of thy
love
through jesus christ our lord
amen
the russian kentuckian for the departed
to remind us that prince philip was
christened into the greek orthodox
[Music]
church
[Music]
is
[Music]
last
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we make us
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
my friends
[Music]
now the most holy part of the service
prince philip's soul
is commended to god
go forth upon thy journey from this
world
o christian soul in the name of god the
father almighty
who created thee in the name of jesus
christ who suffered for thee
in the name of the holy spirit who
strengtheneth thee
may thy portion this day be in peace
and thy dwelling in the heavenly
jerusalem
amen
and for the last time we hear the styles
and titles of the prince
before he becomes an ordinary soul
before god
thus it hath pleased almighty god to
take
out of this transferred life unto his
divine mercy
the late most high mighty and
illustrious prince
philip duke of edinburgh earl of
maryanath and baron greenwich
knight of the most noble order of the
garter night of the most ancient and
most noble order of the thistle
member of the order of merit night grand
cross of the royal victorian order
upon whom had been conferred the royal
victorian chain
grand master and night grand cross the
most excellent order of the british
empire
lord high admiral of the united kingdom
one of her majesty's most honorable
privy council
admiral of the fleet field marshal in
the army
and marshall of the royal air force
husband of her most excellent majesty
elizabeth ii
by the grace of god of the united
kingdom of great britain
and northern ireland and of her other
realms and territories queen
head of the commonwealth defender of the
faith
sovereign of the most noble order of the
garter
whom may god preserve and bless with
long life health and honor and all
worldly happiness
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the last post
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
following ravelli action stations
[Music]
oh
save our
[Music]
the
grace
send her this
[Applause]
[Applause]
usa
some of the key moments there of today's
funeral service for his royal highness
prince philip duke of edinburgh the
quirky touches of the land rover he
designed to carry his coffin
through to the buglers from the royal
marines and the sounding of action
stations
it will no doubt be remembered as a
reflection of him
a reminder of how he was always
respectful of tradition
dedicated to a life of public service
but also
not afraid to do things differently
his royal highness the duke of edinburgh
born out of windsor castle
leaves it now his duty done
[Music]
so
we have been in